let's move on to the next proposal and
this is the one that i mentioned earlier
this was the headline at nfl.com
the league is going to consider making
roughing the passers subject to replay
review and my first reaction to that
was have we already forgotten
the disaster that was past interference
being subject to replay review because
chris
i can see it now i can i can hear al
riveron explaining
that when we reviewed the available
video there was clear and obvious
evidence
of a forcible blow to the head of the
court you know
things that that we're going to say wait
a minute
but but when you break it down frame by
frame because
roughing the passer is so nebulous
there's so many different ways you can
commit roughing the passage yeah right
and you're going to slam the brakes on
the game and think about this after
every interception
they're going to have to look and see
was they're roughing the passer because
it's all
automatic review after a turnover every
interception
was there roughing the passer there's
ten different ways i think
to to commit roughing the passer so you
got to scan the replay angles for that
and see if there's any evidence clear
and obvious evidence of a violation of
the rule i just
i don't like it because they proved to
us two years ago
they don't know how to properly handle
replay review when there's any type of
judgment involved in the ruling on the
field yeah no doubt i i don't want to
see it you know first off roughing the
passer has just gone
it's annoying i mean come on
it's too nice right now it's still
football i mean we're getting into the
point here where it's like
well his pinky finger touched his right
temple
and we got to throw a penalty and then
we see games like this
where you're like yeah patrick mahomes
got his head ripped off twice
and damma consu hit him with a right
hook to his face
and it didn't get caught you know uh it
i i i don't trust it you're right i
don't trust it i don't want to see it be
reviewed
you know we've already gone too far i
think with protecting the quarterback in
my opinion
we have hey i like the low hit thing and
all of that but there is too many
variables and it is going to be too much
on just
like one guy to make a a call and we've
seen two where we're
sitting there watching sunday football
where
you know roughing the pastors called and
okay like yeah by the letter of the law
that's roughing the passer but
you know this is a 290 pound guy who was
running as fast as he can
and now a 315 pound guy pushed him
really hard
and we get roughing the passer out of
that you know
i don't like that aspect of it all and i
don't want to see that become a replay
review and become open up another can of
worms and have all those issues along
with it
it wasn't completely fleshed out in the
article i assume that the door swings
both ways where if it wasn't called on
the field it can be called via
replay review and the flip side is if it
is called on the field it can be picked
up
via replay i mean if it was only one way
yeah that would be a little better it
was
well but here's the problem right if the
rule is that it can
it can be subject to replay review if
it's called
and they can look at it and pick up the
flag then
what the the the the default is going to
be throw the flag they'll clean it up
on replay review i just think the door
has to swing both ways yeah you're right
that's a good point
i don't like it anyway i mean think
about it the forcible blow to the head
when you see it at full speed it looks
one way when you break it down
yeah frame by frame right it's going to
look a different way right that's what
happened with pass interference
so i i don't like it i don't like it i
agree with you
i i now you still have to protect the
quarterback yeah i understand
i understand you gave your spleen to the
profession so you you know
well i just grew up in an era where yeah
i'm a little different and the screw the
hell with me
i don't care you know but i just still
believe in but but no you're right i
mean i
still believe in like defensive
intimidation you know what i mean
there's still that aspect of it and
we've we've lost that a little
you know like with even the lost it a
lot a lot you're right thank you a lot
we've lost that a lot
you know i mean we've literally have
gotten to the point where quarterbacks
can just go
well i'm going to throw down the middle
i know it's a little tight here but
man you know he'll catch it or he'll get
crushed and we'll get a free 15 yards
oh he got a concussion so what we got 15
yards i made a horrible decision
first down i mean that to me is an issue
with the game right now and i don't like
that
that book i mentioned the other day last
20 years in the nfl
100 plus essays one of the topics is the
the reaction to the october 17 2010
bang bang bang of bang bang plays where
three helmet-to-helmet hits happened and
everything
kind of stopped in its tracks and what
are we going to do about defenseless
receivers
that was the argument that mike tomlin
made at the time behind closed doors
i don't want to i don't want to give
away too much of the stuff i'm going to
have in the book
yeah tomlin was pissed sorry london
because we play with intimidation
we play rough and tumble violent
football
this rule that protects defenseless
receivers against blows to the head and
neck area
hurts us more than it hurts anyone else
he eventually came around yeah
eventually came around yeah but as of
2010
he was livid about this so yeah and and
another reason for the nfl to drop
games onto tuesdays and wednesdays they
they don't need to just
fear the xfl or the aaf or some other
spring league realizing we're better off
playing tuesdays and wednesdays
the thing the nfl needs to fear more
than anything else
is someone saying instead of dropping
five billion on an nfl team yeah drop
one billion
on a league that plays football
under the rules and i'm not saying i
advocate this yeah i'm just saying i'm
surprised it hasn't happened yet
someone who drops a billion dollars to
develop a football league that plays
with the rules from the 80s and the 90s
right because
no one can say they don't know the risks
now can you imagine
the people who would flock to watch
games
that were played like and if you just
pull up
any any game yeah on youtube from the
80s or 90s
right the difference in the level of
violence
is jarring yes and i think the nfl needs
to be concerned about that you push it
too far
somebody's gonna say we're gonna we're
gonna make an old school football league
or whatever they call it
and we're gonna play football the way it
used to be played you know people are
gonna be upset about that is it morally
proper those are all fair questions
but you know what football players will
sign up to play it in a heartbeat
yeah and they they'd still sign up in a
heartbeat right now
like right now in the nfl if they would
change it you know i'm all for
i don't want to see forcible blows to
the head or launching to the head and
all that let's protect
that but if a wide receiver goes over
the middle
and the dumb quarterback throws the ball
and
okay the receiver didn't have two steps
to catch the ball and do all that like
that crap has got to go
it's gotta go i don't care you know yeah
sorry
the receiver's gotta look at his coat i
mean his quarterback and go what the
hell are you doing
why are you putting me out there in the
middle to get crushed by
fred warner and as long as that hits
clean and not to the head
i don't care that's part of playing
football it is and
it's taken away to mike tomlin's point
because
hey it's guys like him that are at the
biggest disadvantage with a rule like
this
he has a he's a defensive coach he has a
keen
eye for talented linebackers and
safeties
he's been around the derrick brooks and
the ryan chaziers and they just drafted
a devin bush
and he had a troy palomalu he has a keen
eye for that talent and that type of
player
let alone he coaches his team to be
aggressive in the most physical team on
the field too
and he gets totally screwed over by that
and that's not fair and that's where i i
don't like it and i wish they would take
that
that rule away protect the head no
launching at the head or anything like
that
but you know again your quarterback
throws the ball down the middle
and it's a stupid decision i i don't
know they got to find some way to
to make that even right now the
quarterback
and the offense are being allowed to
make bad decisions
and they're getting rewarded for it and
that's my biggest
problem in the sport right now it's one
of the my my biggest pet peeves
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports